shocking news just kidding not shocking
at all a new study finds that raising
the minimum wage a sort of reasonable
amount relative to the cost of living
has economic benefits and generally
improves people's lives many
right-wingers will tell you that if you
raise the minimum wage right especially
to $15 an hour as many Democrats want to
do it'll be the apocalypse businesses
will close widespread unemployment
unfortunately the facts don't really
bear that out we have a new study
conducted by UC Berkeley which proves
the opposite they looked at Seattle
Washington and they looked at Seattle's
$15 minimum wage and it worked really
really well the study used the rest of
Washington's economy as sort of control
to predict what would have happened in
Seattle if they had not increased the
minimum wage to $15 On January 1st of
this year the $15 minimum wage took
effect and now unemployment is lower
than it's been in Seattle for nearly a
decade in Seattle wages are up
unemployment is down and the number of
hours worked is up meaning that
employers aren't cutting hours to
account for the higher minimum wage this
was even true in the restaurant industry
even at fast-food restaurants which is a
common example from the right the
Conservatives like to say oh well it's
when you raise the minimum wage it's
particularly bad for fast-food
restaurants and the truth is people
weren't being laid off and the way
Republicans said would happen the higher
minimum wage drew people to those
fast-food jobs not away and those
workers are also able to themselves as a
result of earning a higher salary have a
higher standard of living and these
these are meaningful trends right the
data here is really impactful because
Seattle didn't just suddenly raise its
minimum wage six months ago they've been
slowly and steadily raising it over the
last several years up to $15 per hour at
the beginning of this year and things
have been progressively getting better
and better since the beginning of these
increases the study found that instead
of the new minimum wage making it harder
for businesses to find what are called
low skilled employees it's causing
surrounding communities to raise their
wages to compete with the new
opportunities in Seattle companies are
struggling
when they're not paying their workers
enough instead of the other way around
you hero with minimum wage goes up that
will make companies struggle no the
company's not paying the higher wages
are struggling and some of this is
pretty intuitive right if people have
more money to spend because the minimum
wage went up that will help businesses
including fast food since people earning
in that range are more likely to go to
fast food restaurants as well and more
and more people are working they're
working more hours they're getting paid
more
all of which stimulates the economy
Seattle is the first major city to raise
its minimum wage in this way and this is
now going to become part of a larger
study at Berkeley to look at other
cities raising their minimum wages this
is very good news right and
conservatives have this talking point
that if you raise the minimum wage then
you have to make up for it by lowering
hours or cutting staff in some way as if
there's no other factors there and I
understand that you know a company may
budget out a certain amount to labor
costs or but you there's other things in
that pie chart right like for example
corporate profits and when you're
talking about big companies like
McDonald's or Walmart they can easily
afford to do that no doubt about it and
it is not it is not a linear
relationship right if you raise wages X
you don't have to raise all prices that
exact same percentage and by the way
there's another really common
conservative talking point from those
who try to debunk the minimum wage which
is listen if $15 is better than $12 and
more money for everybody is good why not
make the minimum wage $200 an hour and
then everything would be great see you
couldn't so you shouldn't raise the
minimum wage at all no one is asking for
that that is a total red herring that is
not an equilibrium wage given the cost
of living and productivity and what you
need to make in order to have a livable
wage there's no economic argument for a
$200 an hour minimum wage just because
$15 is better than 12 or maybe 18 would
be better than 15 it doesn't mean that
any serious people are calling for a
$200 minimum wage so please do not fall
for that when right-wingers say that if
raising the minimum wage is good just
keep on raising it it's not a serious
economic argument that anybody is making